we have a situation here where we are
trying to optimize and you know that
because if you skip spoilers right to
the end there you can say it says find
the least possible value of the combined
areas whatever areas those are okay so
whenever you hear like I want the least
of this round want the most of this okay
that's like optimization problem okay
and you can see this question has lots
of pieces to it and I know at first
blush that can be like oh my gosh
there's so much work but they're
actually trying to do you a huge favor
here because they're stepping you
through they're giving you something
appropriate like here's the first stage
and in the second stage and oh if you
don't know how to do the first stage hey
guess what you can just use what we've
given you and just move on to the next
bits okay so they're actually trying to
we call as a scaffold they're trying to
help you out okay
now that we know roughly where our
brains gonna go let's have a look at it
from scratch and what I'd love you to do
is with your pen in hand right with me
I'm gonna put up on the board as well
example right with me what you feel is
the important sailing details okay it
says a piece of wire length 10 meters is
cut into two pieces and used to form two
squares okay pause there's a lot of
information even just there okay so you
imagine long straight piece of wire and
then they cut it right so I'm going to
my first thing that I'm gonna put it on
my arm working is not even like words or
anything it's just a piece of wire
that's been cut into two sections here's
my wire it's ten meters all up so I'm
going to do that on the bottom 10 meters
here's the situation right and then
those two pieces get formed into two
squares so this is going to get turned
into a square of some kind so it's bent
into shape and then this guy also it
gets turned into a square maybe it's
bigger maybe it's smaller I don't know
let's get going it says let one piece of
wire have length X meters so I've got
two pieces of wire here so I'll just
make the left-hand one over here X
meters and then they say find the side
length of each square okay that's a nice
easy sort of stepping point so if I've
got this guy here we'll start
because we've got information and you
bend that into a square you've got four
sides and because it's square each side
is equally right
so therefore can you tell me how long is
so quick Expo pop-up perfect so let's go
ahead and write down that's X divided by
four meters it's a square I probably
should've done this to begin with but
they're all equal so that's good this is
only though one of the squares it says
find the side length of each square so
now I've got to come over to this
unknown length of wire here now even
though it hasn't been given a label I
can know how long it is
I could call it could I do this by the
way I could call it oh it's another
length right it's an Y who knows what it
is okay but I would rather not do that
for two reasons number one the less
letters I have flying around the better
the simpler will be and number two I
don't need to if you have a look at this
some 10 meters here I've subtracted X so
whatever this ends up being like suppose
that was one meter of wire over there
how much would this one be it would be
10 minus the 1 which is 9 if I had used
up 3 meters over here then this would be
10 minus the 3 which gives me 7 so what
I'm really saying is it's 10 take away
whatever you use for the first squared
does that make sense so I'll write that
down
10 take away whatever you use for the
first square okay now therefore when I
come to the square
that's the amount I have to play with
and just like with the original square I
have to do that 4 times right so I guess
my length T will be 10 minus X and the
whole thing is divided by 4 is that okay
in um amuse okay fantastic tick that was
part a I wasn't too um that wasn't too
painful was it the next thing it says
show that the combined area of the
squares is and then they give you this
equation okay now this equation is
really important I'm actually going to
ask us to write down Part B this
equation here I have to show that it's
the case so I want this to be my final
line or whatever that is okay so I'm
required to prove that what is it a
equals
one over eight what's in there it's a
quadratic of some kind right x squared
minus 10x what's on the end here I can't
quite see it
plus plus 50 minus with you plus 15 okay
great
oh now this thing here right maybe you
want to put some colors on this this guy
here's what we call the model this is
the thing we're trying to construct
right now like I said this question is
nice to you they've actually even told
you hey this is this is the model you
need to end up here if we wanted to make
this question harder we would just say
find the model yourself we're not going
to tell you what it's equal to this
question is entire in intending to try
and sort of nudge you in the right
direction and in such a cases maybe
you're running out of time or you do not
know how you can actually just take this
model you might be able to get the marks
of Part B but you could get marks apart
C and D by just using the one that they
hand it to you okay
this is what we want to prove how do we
do it what is a stand for have a look at
the question tells you it's the area of
what it's the area of both squares
combined right so that's very important
so what I can say is so here's my proof
the area is equal to and then I've got
like side legs so I can turn side
lengths into actual areas right I'm this
first one here will be x over 4 and then
what do I do to get the area I square it
cuz it's a square right so that's
squared I then got my other square on
the right hand side so I'll do the same
thing like so okay now one of the nice
things about them having handed me a
model is it sort of means I don't have
to simplify in random directions I want
to head towards this right so I noticed
that you see how they've got the 1 over
8 just hanging out the front sort of
factorize there now so I can see where
that's gonna sort of come from do you
notice I have this common denominator on
the bond I've got on 4 and I've won on 4
and they're both square do you notice
that so when you square it what do you
get for when you square it maybe 16
right so what I'm gonna get at the front
is 1 over 16 that's not 1 over 8 but
hopefully like this is gonna simplify in
some way I'll get some factorization and
all that so if I take that out what that
leaves me with
something simpler inside I've just got
that x squared do you see how I
factorize the four squared out okay and
then here I've got hmm 10 minus X all
squared 10 minus X or squared
I think that's 100 minus 20x plus x
squared but that's in brackets there so
it doesn't matter cuts a plus sign is
that okay that is that 10 minus X whole
squared they'll do it right yeah okay it
looks like I've done everything that 1
out of 16 applies this as well and
hopefully if I collect a few like terms
here things are going to work out to me
and get towards where I know I'm
supposed to end up ok so again how do I
get this oh yeah what did I do here
I have to multiply by sorry I have to
add the product of these two yeah so
square this Square this and then double
the product of the middle okay right um
when I collect like terms I'm gonna get
2x squared I'll put this in order I've
got plus 100 back is this looking like
what I want it to look like yeah I'm
very close on time to get to here all I
need to do is factorize out the these
are all even aren't they two negative 20
100 so I'm going to factorize that out
it is worth saying but even though they
were trying to help us out by giving us
the model the upshot of that is because
you know where you're headed
you can't leave any steps out like
you've got to show every single thing
you do because you're like you're not
going to get any marks for that they
gave that to you right so now I'm going
to finish and say it's 1 over 8 as
required plus 50 as required okay so
this is really good we've made great
progress you can see Part A Part B just
check them again did it look good have
we done everything that's been asked us
so far ok now I'm going to hit pause
from because this is the point where the
last example we did like half an hour
ago picks up in that example I just
handed you the model and I said find me
a maximum find me a minimum have a look
at what Part C and D are asking I think
you guys can partly take over from here
I'll show you the example after you had
a
Part C says find da on the X hmm push
minute we normally normally have
something like this and then we get dy
on DX right why is there a DA on DX over
there right because our our model is
about area okay this is why I said
before in our first three example
questions it matters what you call these
things because in my pan area might be
volume out their population could be
anything okay so please use what that's
giving you you're going to differentiate
search for a minimum and then I'll give
you three four minute head start and
then I'll put my work up on the board
just to show you're in the right
direction